ونبقى في تونس التي غادرها اكثر من
ثلاثمائه من طالب اللجوء ينتمون الى دول
افريقيه بين هاغينيا ومالي وكوت ديفوار
الى بلدانهم خوفا من موجه عنف بعد تصريح
للرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد مثير للجدل بشان
المهاجرين وقال دبلوماسي مليء طائره تقل
133 مواطنا ماليا غادرت تونس السب كما
اعلن سفير كوت ديفوار في تونس ان طائره
اخرى تحمل 145 من مواطني اقلعت من تونس في
اليوم ذاته وكان سعيد قد طلب المسؤولين
باتخاذ اجراءات عاجله للتصدي للهجره غير
النظاميه قائلا ان هناك مؤامره اجراميه
جاريه لتغيير التركيبه الديموغرافيه في
تونس من جانب اكدت الخارجيه التونسيه في
وقت سابق ان السلطات التونسيه لم ترى حل
اي او لم ترح ل اي مواطن اجنبي بصفه قصريه
من بين الجاليات الموجوده في تونس
وقال محمد بن غونا المكلف بالعلاقات
الخارجيه في جمعيه الطلبه والمتدربين
الجابونيين في تونس انهم يعيشون اوضاعا
مقلقه واضاف بانجون في مقابله مع الجزيره
في نشره سابقه ان الاوضاع في تونس كانت
افضل في الماضي وان كثيرا من الطلاب لم
يعودوا يستطيعون الالتحاق بفصولهم وباتوا
يتابعون دراستهم عن بعد
ومعقد عشنا اوقات جيده في السابق لكن الان
هناك الكثير من الخوف والقلق والترقب لما
ستؤول اليه الاوضاع في تونس بعد تصريحات
رئيس الجمهوريه السيد قيس سعيد التي يمكن
وصفها بالعنصريه وتمثل جزءا من المجتمع
التونسي لكنها بالتاكيد لا تمثل كل تونس